hey Vsauce Michael here the dog that
played Toto in The Wizard of Oz was
credited as toto but in reality the
dog's name was Terry and when Terry died
in 1945 her owner and trainer Carl Spitz
buried her on his ranch in Los Angeles
but in 1958 the Ventura Highway was
constructed right through Terry's grave
her remains were disturbed and have
never been found 53 years later a
memorial was erected in Hollywood
Forever Cemetery in her honor but
because she isn't buried there the
memorial is not a grave it's what's
known as a Cenotaph an empty tomb I was
reminded of todos Cenotaph when I saw
the Cenotaph of philopappos atop the
hill of the muses in Athens you see I
was recently in Greece talking about
YouTube with YouTube creators the
all-seeing eye of guy came along and we
visited the Acropolis a lion gate nearly
a thousand years older than the
Acropolis
the earliest known analog computer
plenty of beautiful cats and I even took
a selfie in Delfy I've seen all of these
things and how old they were made me
wonder how will we be remembered how
will future archaeologists react to the
ruins of today's society they find
thousands of years from now
will they do a good job piecing it
together will anything about you in
particular be remembered
and for that matter how do we even know
that the past really happened not just
the way we think it happened but at all
seriously can you prove that the
universe wasn't created last Thursday
that everything every person every
memory you have every photo you've taken
didn't just pop into existence last week
or five minutes ago last Thursday ISM is
the belief that the universe was created
last Thursday it doesn't have actual
followers or rituals but proving it
wrong is impossible not because the
universe actually was created last
Thursday but because last Thursday ISM
is not falsifiable it cannot be shown to
be false any evidence you bring up
against it can be explained away as part
of the everything that was created last
Thursday many people believe that in
order for a theory and explanation to be
scientific it must be possible to refute
it to prove it wrong to test it
so instead last Thursday ISM falls into
the domain of philosophy where luckily
there are razors little rules of thumb
that help shave off unlikely
explanations the most famous is Occam's
razor when faced with the choice between
explanations choose the one that
requires the fewest assumptions Occam's
razor can shave off last thursday's
because it requires fewer assumptions to
believe that say this beehive tomb was
constructed way back in the Bronze Age
and that I just visited it later than it
does to believe that the tomb my
memories of it and this footage of me
inside it just happened to
incidentally pop into existence at the
same time
last Thursday one of my favorite
philosophical razors cuts off so much
stuff it's not even called a razor
it's called Newton's flaming laser sword
it states if something cannot be settled
by experiment then it is not worthy of
debate so let's move on to the past
what does Newton's flaming laser sword
tell us about the past I mean it doesn't
exist in the same way gravity or light
or protons do we can't do experiments on
it build control groups run trials the
past just is what it was we will one day
be the past and no matter how well we
try to record our stories ourselves
without time machines future
archaeologists are going to have to make
a lot of guesses about us but that's
kind of cool
future humans will likely know way more
than us today about medicine about
exoplanets about physics but one thing
they almost surely will not know more
about than we do is today will your
great great great great grandkids know
your name will a Lian's
who visit earth millions of years after
humans leave or go extinct understand
that Animorphs was just fiction and not
a history of our people you're destined
to become whatever the future thinks you
were if you're lucky
vandals fire natural disaster conquerors
thieves all of these forces obscure
facts over time but no matter how well
we try to preserve today for future
history books there's one type of fog we
are unlikely to avoid
apathy Ira Glass put it well when he
asked his listeners a simple question
name 10 people from the 15th century we
have records of more than 10 people but
to most of us they don't matter in 500
years radio hosts will be making the
same jokes but about us however there is
a legacy you leave behind that is
irreversible immutable and in a way
unforgettable to conserve energy turn
off when not in use or just keep them on
energy will be conserved no matter what
you do even if you leave lights on all
year there will be no less or more
energy in the universe what's really
being conserved when we turn off lights
are the resources we turn into energy
the lights can use but if you counted up
all the energy in the system before and
after turning the lights on it would be
the same energy also does something else
unless hindered from doing so energy
will spread out it will disperse that is
in so few words the second law of
thermodynamics it's how our universe
works it's why things that happen
spontaneously do energy spreads even
when a process locally concentrates
energy like when a crystal forms or life
grows the second law isn't violated
because these processes aren't
independent from the larger world around
them they aren't 100% efficient
hindrances can hold back the inevitable
spread of energy for a long time the
second law doesn't say when energy will
disperse just that when it can
oh it will balloons will deflate objects
will fall hot objects will cool down and
perfume sprayed across the room will
eventually migrate to your nose even and
really still air how much or how widely
energy has spread out is measured in
entropy entropy is often called disorder
chaos but entropy is very different from
macroscopic
messiness this deck of cards is themed
after Greek philosophers it's also
arranged by value and suit the entire
deck but if I take the deck and shuffle
it that is disorder it I haven't
actually increased the decks entropy
because nothing about this deck of cards
is energy is different than it was
before
however entropy in the greater world
around us has increased because in order
to shuffle the cards my body has to do
work it has to take energy concentrated
in my cells and change and disperse that
energy into kinetic energy movement and
a little bit of heat from my body and
from the cards friction and a little bit
of sound energy that rustling noise so
there's your real legacy your
contribution to the universe's growing
entropy no process will be able to undo
the net increase in entropy you
accomplished in your life history may
forget you or misinterpret your
accomplishments or what you stood for
the ripples you leave behind may get
redirected but the you
we'll never be able to forget the
entropy you act that's the law the
second law of thermodynamics many
scientists believe that this means that
eventually energy heat will be
completely spread out evenly throughout
the universe it will be the same
temperature everywhere and at that point
nothing will be able to happen because
in order for something to happen
entropy needs to increase energy needs
to spread to move to change this may be
the ultimate fate of the universe
thermodynamic equilibrium the heat death
of the universe it's been estimated that
at the rate things happen this end of
the universe will occur in about a
googol years and you're contributing to
it by simply existing a funny
consequence of all of this is the fact
that people who aren't very active
people who don't do much but lay around
aren't just being lazy in a way they're
being considerate sloth maybe a vice but
to the universe it's a fountain of youth
choosing to do as little as possible
means consciously limiting your
contribution to the inevitable dispersal
of energy and thus in a teeny tiny way
postponing the heat death of our
universe relaxing adds time to the
universe's life an amount of time to be
fair almost indistinguishable from zero
but still theoretically real being lazy
will make the universe last longer so
thanks for cheering out thanks for
taking it easy and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]